[Música]
la emergencia sanitaria por kobe 19 ha
provocado grandes cambios a nivel
mundial y el tema educativo no es la
excepción la organización de las
naciones unidas nos habla que en más de
190 países se tuvieron que interrumpir
clases presenciales afectando a 1500
millones de estudiantes en todo el mundo
las cifras de la secretaría de educación
pública nos dicen que desafortunadamente
en el ciclo escolar 2020 2021 dejaron de
asistir a la escuela 5.2 millones de
estudiantes sin lugar a dudas la
pandemia ha tocado no solamente temas
sociales sino también educativos y esto
es lamentable sin embargo también hay
que decir que la pandemia nos ha dado la
posibilidad de reinventarnos cierto es
estamos en una emergencia sanitaria
cierto es que también hemos tenido que
cambiar incluso la forma de dar clase
como docente puedo decirles que he
experimentado varios cambios
en este trayecto de la pandemia desde la
frustración la tristeza y también la
satisfacción del deber cumplido
es la pandemia quien me ha permitido
reinventarme pero también le ha
permitido reinventarse a estudiantes y a
profesores
poco a poco hemos tenido que adaptar
este proceso de enseñanza-aprendizaje
con la finalidad de dar lo mejor de
nosotros mismos muchos expertos en
educación dicen que en este momento la
pandemia marca un hito un antes y un
después de nuestra vida un antes y un
después en la educación y cierto es en
este momento todas y todos nos
convertimos en aprendices
somos aprendices de la pandemia
la la pandemia nos ha hecho sacar lo
mejor de nosotros mismos salir de
nuestra zona de confort e ir más allá
buscar elementos que nos permitan
avanzar y no quedarnos estancados si
algo positivo ha tenido la pandemia es
que nos ha permitido reinventarnos una y
otra vez desaprender para volver a
aprender a muchos docentes nos daba
miedo entrar en este para muchos
desconocido mundo de la tecnología sin
embargo es en este momento cuando
podemos decir que poco a poco lo hemos
conseguido
estamos aprendiendo aprendiendo todos y
todas en época de pandemia
una de las cuestiones más importantes es
que hemos aprendido a darle valor a lo
que en muchas ocasiones pensamos o
creíamos como seguro
un abrazo
y una plática
y las charlas con los buenos amigos todo
esto ha quedado de manifiesto y le hemos
dado un valor superior
a que nos invita a la pandemia a que
sigamos aprendiendo a que sigamos
reinventándonos y creando conciencia
siendo hombres y mujeres más empáticos
solidarios
reinventándonos
siendo por horarios pero sobre todo
entendiendo que todos los días tenemos
la posibilidad de hacer y de ser mejores
personas
no podemos decir que la pandemia sea
buena o sea mala simplemente es lo que
sí podemos decir es que en este momento
tenemos la posibilidad de elección
y nada es para siempre
y aquí cabe perfectamente una hermosa
reflexión nadie se baña dos veces en el
mismo río
porque la segunda vez que te sumerges ni
el río mito son los mismos